para muchos uno de los mítines más
cruciales importantes de las últimas
décadas ese de ahí es el escenario donde
el líder opositor que mal kilitzarolulu
comparece ante los miles de asistentes
que se han congregado al evento se
espera que la cifra de simpatizantes sea
enorme y como podemos observar el
optimismo es aquí total un optimismo que
se veía venir desde el mismo transporte
público donde hemos venido que estaba
totalmente colapsado en ocho días todas
estas personas acudirán en masa para
votar previsiblemente a una oposición
que lleva más de 20 años alejada del
poder es por ello que los partidos
opositores también han Unido fuerzas
para abatir a erdogan en estas
elecciones el principal argumento para
captar al votante ha sido señalar una
economía en sus horas más bajas y una
inflación que según apuntan académicos
independientes roza el 100% algo que el
mismo gobierno de erdogan niega y sitúa
la cifra en el 40% también destaca la
campaña de la campaña opositora el
mensaje democratizador que quieren
transmitir al país por lo tanto queda
poco más de una semana para que toda
esta gente Todos los surcos acudan a las
urnas para decidir si quieren seguir con
el modelo de erdogan por el contrario
quieren un cambio de gobierno
[Música]